Laurent, no matter how much
you mix into that candy,
my customers won't...
Such happiness
from just one piece of candy.
This is the latest synthetic drug
created by Japan,
a leading country in pharmaceutics.
It's magic,
or you could say "Sakura Magic."
Eddie, I'll sell exclusively to you.
The wholesale price for a pack of 1,000
is 10,000 dollars.
Including the doctor's compensation,
initial fee,
and the exclusive contract fee,
it's five million dollars.
In cash.
That's an absurd price.
Since it's an absurd drug.
You can carry it around,
and there's no worry about
scarring or rhinitis.
Urine tests can't detect it.
If we have an exclusive contract,
celebrities from all over the world
would buy from you.
And who can make it?
That's right.
It's this young expert from
the Chemical Research Institute of Japan.
The one and only Dr. Edamura.
Might as well.
Is there anyone else who'd like to try?
Give me some!
-I was here first.
-Give me some.
-Hey.
-All right.
How about
whoever takes the doctor's glass?
What did you say?
Open your mouth.
Hey, everyone, isn't the doctor amazing?
You'll get higher if you swallow it whole.
All right, which mouth should I put it in?
Damn it.